give me a bigger happy Thanksgiving
y'all this is the Puffin fluff then the
puffins flock is an As Seen on TV
product that guarantees that you are
gonna get your dog dry in minutes vote
in top 10 dog dryers of 2016 top 10 fun
fact about dogs dogs love the
circulating warm air also attach
virtually any blow-dryer that's kind of
come in handy if there was ever a thing
called foreshadowing on YouTube that is
certain fluff requires one dog a lot of
water
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
what is the saddest face I've ever seen
all right anyway so
and call attention to this this little
Victor I don't know if you can zoom in
enough that you see it that is that is
hilarious
you can tell it's hilarious by how much
I'm laughing at it hey you guys didn't
come here to see chica get bathe songs
good oh she could you gotta get naked
cue the sexy music
[Music]
[Music]
yeah cut the sexy music and you do
nothing I guess
I would also like to take this time to
bring attention to a very underrated and
struggling channel I know it's sad shut
up shut up it's not whining like a
little [ __ ] anyway I'd like to bring
attention to this channel they need your
help and they need your help
now I've linked them in the description
teachers they desperately desperately
desperately need your subscription T
series makes wholesome content for
everybody to enjoy good quality content
the world around needs to see more of
and you need in your life
help them help them now they're
struggling they need your help
links in the description oh yeah Casey
Casey nice fat is that you what do you
think I think you should subscribe to PD
fight good girl
I'd like to bring you guys at home to
smellivision of what's happening right
now
oh it's berry smells like grandma's
Thanksgiving dinner which is cute you
guys
my grandma's Korean pewdiepie needs your
support subscribe subscribe subscribe
subscribe
what do you think about to shave
t-series and to the side of your for a
writer
please don't you be proud not proud no
no Emily if you'd be proud no way Jose
you'd apply for life you go subscribe to
series so you don't
gotta get your undercarriage okay
nothing personal well I'm about to get
all up in your business
[Music]
well this funny is the sound effects I'm
having at this one point
ahaha listen to me narc is Adam and
doesn't know what he's talking about
help you deep eye right now link in bio
Casey Casey don't help help ill Kizzy
help help help help help
don't can play at that game chica it's
begun the drain gonna get up in that
business all backs when I bring back
their joke from before the part where
it's actually important
[Music]
I am upset
oh I feel excluded this isn't fair
though
you suck the big ol you are just jealous
that PewDiePie has more subscribers than
you you are a saint I love you I love
you I love you I love you I love you I
love you I love you I love you bye stay
stay need I remind this video is about a
puffin flock about a puffin fluff is an
ingenious design we design to blow an
ingeniously designed invention that gets
your dog dry in minutes
when I say dry I mean dry as a bone
no this is the hair cause the 200 the
tube okay that's
there's a lot of jokes here there's a
lot of jokes I'm better than that
cuz it's Thanksgiving and sit or don't
sit that's fine too okay now oh we're
gonna go in the back I don't know how
you go in the bag this is what's known
as oh [ __ ] tail convenient instructions
for the little lady
okay okay okay you remember how you
remember how you don't move don't move
this is for your own good
that's not bad it is for your own good
I'm not saying that in a threatening way
it's lieutenant Lee for your own good
it's this is for your goodness does this
good for you this is good
Henry get your plot out of there unless
you want to go in the bag next not cheap
we're going back
it's back it's like a Batman you carry
with you
you're good wherever you go like a
little lady then you cinch this up right
tight like that it's about to blow in
[Music]
save me blue cloak brand calm save me
it's made for me and forgive the Puffin
cloth it works to be credible science
and thermodynamic blowing you taste okay
don't worry about thing yeah that's
right that's right
you instert you instert not insert you
and start you in you instruct you in
Sturt you in oh my god God you insert
you ins I'm just gonna hold it
you insert the blower directly into the
proboscis of the puffin floss and then
you just set to warm not hot
see sterility all right let me know if
they've done this harmony like for
instance as you can see through the
packages blowing technology the puppets
love cries as it blows who's completely
kaput be lovely if you give leafy puppy
and therefore in minutes
Chico will be dry as a bone no no no no
no no this patented process saves hours
of laborious drying from your life no
longer will you be subjected to the
constant pressures of dry got wet dogs
you too can have a dry dog with buffing
block
the extra air is vented out the other
man's prevent splashes populo integrity
Gobert you're not dry I bet there's no
way come here dad
Sid can you sit new Duke is it looks
like a buttonhole like she's pooping on
her own tail
so it's to blow it into blue dog air but
I think I gotta blow blow blow
please big balls
we spent good you like it I'm getting
tears
shoot me back into my mouth
okay it's not very puffed and I'm not
skilled enough all right so it's not
very puffed and I'm not skilled enough
blower to be able to supply enough air
but we've got a back-up plan
cuz think about it things operate in two
different ways in life they either blow
or they suck and if you turn something
that sucks around suddenly it starts
blowing what am I talking about a vacuum
cleaner anyway so I can't move no
chicken no change with me
they were this Caravan with many things
that blow and go suck think about it
it's only science if you suck in it's
got to go somewhere you gotta suck in
order to blow remember that it's a life
lesson so when you're sucking just
remember that a blows always around the
nearest corner not only can you make
life suck with tech you can make it blow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
and what we have here is a bone-dry
drier than the desert so dry no moisture
anywhere to speak of
unbeliev a dry one dry Papas
father your dumb stupid plan didn't work
but I still love you despite appearances
I am wearing pants by the way I didn't
just suddenly change that in between the
shots anyway thank you everybody so much
for watching if you want to see more
bathtub videos that I've made I'll put
them all in the description below or all
the ones that I can find anyway and if
you've got other crazy ideas for me in
bathtubs with various items and/or
animals I guess let me know down the
comments below and if you got any other
crazy ideas let me know down there as
well thanks everybody so much for
supporting my channel and thanks to
everybody so much for being here on this
Thanksgiving Day if you celebrate it if
you don't celebrate it you're watching
it's a future it doesn't matter thank
you for being here and as always we'll
see you in the next video bye bye